hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're going to
be going over our third video for the
upcoming graphic novel Bobby Fischer the
knight who killed the kings now if you
do want more information about the
upcoming graphic novel we will have a
link below in the video description now
in this particular video we're going to
be going over the 1966 u.s. championship
and this is actually Bobby Fischer's
last US Championship video ever played
now he did end up winning eight years in
a row up to this given time he was the
seven-time champion so pretty much
everyone that he played knew that they
were playing the seven-time champion
which I think in this particular game
played a huge role as his opponents will
see later on actually had an advantage
and could have won the game but
miscalculated and actually ended up
losing the game to Bobby Fischer during
this particular game Bobby Fischer was
23 years old his opponent is 38 year old
paul banco paul banco as many people
know out there is the founder of the
banco gambit one of the most popular
openings and also the bingo opening
which he actually used in this game now
that opening starts out with g3 so
definitely definitely a great match we
do have the seven-time reigning champion
verse one of the most winning players in
the US Open Chess Championship and
that's Paul Banco and he's also a member
of the US chess Hall of Fame so very
very well known player in the chess
community so this was a great game for
Bobby Fischer to go out on during the
1966 US Championship we will go ahead
and get into the game
Paul Banco is going to be playing the
white pieces Bobby Fischer at this time
this seven-time reigning champion is
going to be playing the black pieces now
Paul Benko starts out with pawn to g3
and this is the Banco opening if you're
not too familiar with it this is the
opening named after Paul Banco so he is
intimately familiar with this a little
fun fact again this is the 1966 US
Championship only four years prior 1962
at the candidates tournament this
opening was actually introduced in Paul
Banco played Bobby Fischer and actually
beat him with this opening so definitely
not a very common opening at this time
but Paul Banco probably more familiar
with it than anyone if you know anything
about Bobby Fischer though he's probably
one of the biggest students
the game loves to study opening and
theories and different lines of
different openings if there's one thing
that Bobby Fischer let everyone know is
if you beat him with an opening or you
kind of outplayed him over the board he
was going to make sure that he studied
up and he was more prepared the next
time he ever saw that opening or that
individual so you can rest assure
four years after Paul Banco kind of
introduced this and kind kind of you
know laid the smackdown on Bobby Fischer
he was going to be very very well
prepared when he placed him again and
that's kind of why we're going to be
going over this match so very very
interesting again Paul Benko plays pawn
to d3 Bobby Fischer's going to respond
with pawn to g6 kind of marrying the
move from Paul benka right here
Paul Meiko now decides to play Bishop to
g2 being cutting his bishop to the Kings
side kind of a hyper modern offense
trying to control the sternum board with
his modern pieces before he gets his
pawns involved into the game Bobby
Fischer not going to play Bishop to g7
again being getting his bishop to the
king side as well and now Paul Benko
plays pawn to d4 again realizing that if
Bobby Fischer is not going to try to
control the sin of the world with his
pawns early on he's going to go ahead
and take that initiative himself Bobby
Fischer now plays Knight to f6 again
simple development move trying to
control the stern of the board Paul
Benko plays pawn to e4 again now that
Bobby Fischer has pretty much said he's
not going to try to control the stern of
the board with his pawns early on Paul
Benko is going to again continue that
initiative trying to control with his
pawns Bobby Fischer now plays pawn to d6
very important to note any time you have
bishops in the early of the game you
never want to block off your bishops
behind the pawn chain you're always
going to want to get your bishops out
before you kind of connect that pawn
chain but anytime you feel keto a bishop
to one side most particularly the Kings
side you actually want to if you're
going to have a pawn structure then you
actually want to put those on the same
color so in this particular case since
the dark square Bishop is here on g7
then the pawn structure if you are going
to lock it you actually want to lock it
along those dark squares so that both of
your bishops can actually roam freely
and develop as they need be so this
light square bishop can
involved into the action if he needs to
and also this dark square Bishop is not
blocked off as well so it's just
something to think about in your own
game you never want to be blocking off
your bishops with your pawns Paul Benko
decides to bring Knight to e2 again he
does want to develop his Knights weekend
castle on the Kings side you always do
want King side safety early on to the
game so you can kind of worry about
other things as far as development and
game plan you never want to worry about
your opponent attacking your king
especially if your opponent is Bobby
Fischer he doesn't want to bring let's
say his knight to f3 again this pawn
right here on e4 is only being protected
by this Bishop here on g2 so logical
move here bringing his Knight to e2 sill
still a nice little square protecting
this pawn here on d4 and he can kind of
get into the action later on if he needs
to pretty easily from here Bobby
Fischer's going to cast on the King side
and Paul Benko is going to do the same
Bobby Fischer now plays Knight to d7
again nice little square from him is
going to be supporting later on if he
wants to bring his pawn to c5 he could
always bring his pawn to e5 again really
trying to set up his minor pieces to
support pawns early on if he does want
to push and kind of counter-attack in
the center of the board always do keep
in mind early on your minor pieces
support your pawns your major pieces
support your pawns and your minor pieces
but later on to the game those do kind
of take on different roles now from here
Paul Benko is going to continue what
he's been doing that's continue to push
his pawns try to control the center
right now he's pretty much completely
dominating this fifth rank right here
with his pawns Bobby Fischer's now going
to play pawn to e5 can't just let Paul
Benko dominate the center of the board
the entire game so again this is kind of
why he played this pawn or excuse me
this knight here to d7 so that it would
allow him to play this pawn to e5 now
Paul bancos don't going to continue to
develop his pieces he plays Knight to c3
simple development move trying to
control the soon the board nice little
square for his knight here it is
actually nice that he brought his pawn
out first so pretty much everything is
going to be eyeing down on this d5
square right here there's no piece or
pawn there right now but as you can see
Paul Benko has this pawn this pawn this
bishop right here on g2 this Queen here
on d1 and also this night here on c3 all
kind of looking forward at this square
right here especially if this pawn moves
war to d5 now Bobby Fischer on the
opposite side does have this night here
on f6 and his next move he plays pawn to
c6 so making sure that he does have some
proper defense if paul banco decides to
move forward that's exactly what he does
it tries to push for a little bit more
and try to control that Center Bobby
Fischer takes back and now Paul Banco
has a decision he could if he wanted to
take with this pawn here on c5 so if
you're kind of anal analyzing this game
trying to figure out what you would do
in this situation he does have a few
options obviously he doesn't want to
move his Queen first because Bobby
Fischer has this night here on f6 but he
definitely has this option to bring his
pawn here on d5 if you were white
playing the situation later on you'd
want to bring your dark square Bishop
involved into the game
partly to maybe a g5 square pinning down
this night here on f6 to this Queen here
on d8 after that you would then want to
bring your rook over connect your rooks
on the first rank and then get your rook
over to the C file you always want your
rooks on open files they have a lot more
room to roam around definitely can
support a lot more pieces and move a lot
more than they can when they're not on a
semi open or open file but instead Paul
banker decides instead to take with his
knight on d5 a little more aggressive
move Bobby Fischer obviously is going to
recapture and then from here paul banco
again has the option he can take with
his pawn here but instead he opts for
the more aggressive move and that is
quintics
on b5 now Bobby Fischer knowing that
this pawn here on d6 does need some
protection instead he's going to bring
his a knight down here to c5 nice little
outpost move for his knight right here
it is going to take some time before
this Knight has ever kicked off and
appall banco now plays rook over to d1
again his major pieces are supporting
his other pieces in this case the Queen
here on d5
now Bobby Fischer plays Bishop to g4 now
he could have if you want to just
brought his Bishop to e6 Bobby Fischer
obviously doesn't want to get his
LightSquared and vault life squared
Bishop involved into the game
it is his last minor piece after this
he'll obviously want to get his Queen
involvement to the game and then he can
connect his rooks on the 8th ring can
kind of get them involved as well but
definitely great move from him obviously
he only has two different squares he
coulda brought it to e6 and g4
definitely like the g4 move it's kind of
an in-between move pinning down this
Knight here on e 2 to the rook here on
d1 kind of a pesky move and Paul Baker
responds with pawn to f3 and this is
kind of what Bobby Fischer wanted
obviously he's just going to kick back
his Bishop here to e6 nice little square
for him but as you can see any time you
feel keto your Bishop to one side of the
board any other pawns that you move kind
of give a little more air in a little
more space where your opponent can come
in slip in and attack this King here so
as you can see the king side for black
is a lot safer than the white side just
because that pawn has moved up from f2
to f3 so it's always those in between
moves obviously Bobby Fischer wants to
end up and kick this Queen off of d5 but
very interesting move kind of in between
to come in here and bring this pawn up
to f3 so from here pal Benko plays Queen
takes on d6 obviously he's now supported
by his rook here on d1 and Bobby Fischer
has a few options he could if he wanted
to go ahead and take here on d5 excuse
me on d6 but instead he plays Bishop
takes here on c4 so really trying to
control the center of the board here
with his minor pieces Paul Benko now
decides to bring his knight over to c3
again nice central square wasn't doing a
whole lot was being attacked right here
by the bishop on c4 so definitely wants
to kind of centralize that night so now
it's a great square later on if he wants
he has a nice outpost here on d5 he can
get to so nice central development move
second move from this knight but very
very well placed where he was kind of
misplaced over here on e to Bobby
Fischer now plays Queen to a5 very
important move because he does want to
actually kick this Queen off of d6 and
what he intends to do by bringing his
Queen over here is now he can slide over
one of his rooks he could bring his rook
over from
a file or he could bring it over from
the F file but as you can see the Queen
on a5 is actually protecting this so he
not only has his Queen protecting the DA
file but he also has his other rook
protecting this so as you can see this
Paul Baker is now going to develop his
last piece and he plays a Bishop to g5
again last piece needing development he
is now connected both of his rooks both
sides have connected both of their
Brooks and Paul Benko is forcing that
that rook coming over to d8 so not only
should you think about in your own games
where you should develop your pieces but
you should always think about what your
opponent is trying to doing most times
players are not just you know randomly
moving their pieces especially in this
situation his opponent is Bobby Fischer
he didn't just bring his Queen over to
a5 for no reason at all so definitely
any time you can develop or move a piece
and also throw your opponent's tacks or
plans definitely a good idea now from
here
Bobby Fischer is going to bring his
knight over to e6 nice little square
again allowing this Queen here on a5 to
also protect this pawn here on e5 and
it's also attacking the bishop here on
g5 definitely he wants to bring his rook
over if he can to d8 as we talked about
before
now this Bishop here is thwarting that
attack so a very logical move to bring
his knight over to e6 and attack that
Bishop here on g5 on g5 now from here
Paul bancos going to play Bishop to e7
obviously his bishop is under attack so
he wants to move that so very logical
move to go ahead and be very very
aggressive as you can see Paul bancos
really really trying to come out strong
keep in mind in this tournament this is
the very first round of the tournament
so both players want to come out strong
neither of them want to actually lose
the game if anything they want to you
know make sure they at least get a tie
the last thing you want to do in a major
tournament like this is actually come
out with no points at all with you if
you tie a game you get half a point if
you win you get a whole point so Paul
bancos coming out guns blazing he wants
to go ahead and try to win at least the
first round and get off to a good start
so Bishop to e7
very aggressive move definitely like it
Bobby Fisheries bonds with rook to e8
doesn't have a whole lot of moves that
he can do so just kind of
counter-attacking here with his rook
here on EA now Paul Benko continues to
be aggressive he plays Knight here to d5
again this is a nice little outpost move
from white here Bobby Fischer is
probably not going to exchange most
people especially as this game starts to
open up they typically want to keep
their Bishop pair so a lot of times if
you're looking at you're like why don't
they give up their Bishop for their
Knight that's why top players typically
especially in the open game want to keep
that Bishop pair there now Bobby Fischer
as he usually does it kind of
counter-attacks and he plays Bishop to
to e2 here attacking this rook here on
d1 and Paul Benko just slides it over to
c1 obviously he was trying to control
and support this long D file but now he
is on this long sea foul still a very
very powerful square for him to support
and take control of now at this
situation Paul Benko realized that he
doesn't really have any other attacks
obviously his Bishop really can't do
anything his Queen is being supported
you know
he's supporting this mr. Perron e7 but
he decides kind of to fall back there's
not really anything he can do so he
brings back after Bobby Fischer brings
his knight over to d4 nice little
outpost move for him Paul banker just
brings his queen back here to b4 really
just asking Bobby Fischer if he wants to
go ahead and exchange major pieces and
kind of move towards the end game Bobby
Fischer accepts he brings his Queen
takes on b4 and then Paul Benko
recaptures here on before now the next
move it is probably one of the the
biggest turning points in the game now
Bobby Fischer if you kind of look at
both sides it's fairly equal both sides
are equal in material both sides had a
very very similar middle of the game
they do have a night here on d4 and on
d5 both very nice outposts for each of
those pieces both sides do have a bishop
that's kind of very involved into the
game and they both have a bishop that's
not doing a whole lot both of their feet
and keto bishops are kind of
knocked off by their own pawns right now
and then both sides do have both of
their rooks both on the 1st and the 8th
ring so this is a pretty equal position
right here and as Bobby Fischer
typically does it kind of mixes it up
now in this situation a lot of different
grandmasters and international masters
and people have analyzed this game and
even run it through through powerful
chess engines think that his next move
was was maybe that a mistake but
definitely could have gone and played a
much safer and better move definitely
opened up Pandora's box and allowed his
opponent Paul banker to actually take a
large advantage so the next move from
Bobby Fischer is Knight takes on f3
again attacking the King here on g1 now
this is being supported by this Bishop
on e2 so if you're kind of wondering why
Paul Benko doesn't just go ahead and
take again as we talked about before
players really don't want to trade off
and get rid of that Bishop pair so Paul
Benko instead plays King to f2 and now
interesting move of the game is Bobby
Fischer after he brings his knight to d4
again nice little central square
Paul Banco plays Knight to c7 now he's
attacking and forking both of these
rooks right here but instead of moving
one of them and kind of starting a
counter attack from that way Bobby
Fischer instead plays Bishop to h6 now
in this situation Paul bacos should go
ahead and take one of these rooks it's
going to be very very advantageous he's
going to have a huge advantage if he can
take one of these but instead you can
kind of see with his next move that he
pretty much throws it away Bobby Fischer
in this situation with his
counter-attack I think Bobby Fischer
realized that his knight to f3 was a
little bit ambitious wasn't really going
to be doing a whole lot and so he kind
of playing mind games if you kind of
looked this at this from Paul Benko you
know he came here to c7 attacking both
of these rooks and Bobby Fischer the
seven-time champion comes here to h6 as
though he doesn't even see it so it kind
of feels like Paul Benko is unsure of
him
elf bobby fischer's pretty much wrapped
up a nice little present on Christmas
Day and I guess Paul Benko got that and
not a big Christmas fan but decided to
not wrap unwrapped that thought it was a
trap and actually gave it back to Bobby
Fischer in the form of a terrible move
so instead he plays rook over to e1 kind
of what he should have done he could
have easily played you know Knight takes
on e85 in c1 then the knight can come
back to c7
attacking this rook here on a8 if the
bishop came to be to the rook here can
come to be one again both the bishop
here on b2 and the rook here on a8 or
both being attacked definitely going to
be a much better game for Paul Benko
here but even if Bobby Fischer didn't
come down here if he were to take the
night here on e8 it just kind of said
you know what made a mistake I'll go
ahead and take this back right here
you know Paul Benko could bring his rook
over to c7 this is a fantastic move
anytime you can get your rook on your
opponent's 7th or 2nd rank depending on
if you're wider block that's going to be
very very hard for your opponent to deal
with typically you're going to have
pawns on that 2nd or 7th rank and so you
can pretty much just gobble up a lot of
pawns so this would be a huge huge
advantage for Paul Benko but you can
kind of see that the pressure of playing
Bobby Fischer got to him you can also
see that he didn't want to make a huge
mistake again this is round 1 the last
thing you want to do is come out of
round 1 with 0 points so he played a
move that ended up costing him the game
Bobby Fischer after this move actually
now has the advantage something you
never want to do is give Bobby Fischer
an advantage but again he plays rook
over to e1 and now Bobby Fischer plays
his rook over to c8 now it's a much
different story because after Paul Benko
plays Knight over and takes on a 8 now
Bobby Fischer can bring his rook down to
c2 now one thing that Bobby Fischer does
better than almost anyone in the history
of chess is he really is able to bring
all of his pieces together and have them
work really really well together so as
you can
see this the night over here on a 8's
not doing a whole lot although it did
just capture a piece a major piece from
black but again as I've always talked
about my videos it's not how many pieces
you have on the board it's about how
many pieces you have in the battle
attacking your opponent's king so in
this situation Bobby Fischer actually
has that advantage so if you kind of
look at this before where you know Paul
Benko could have had his rook over here
on c7 really putting a lot of pressure
on Bobby Fischer as you can see right
now all the pressure is starting to
mount on Paul Benko from black so from
here Paul benko is just going to take
this bishop here on e2 and Bobby Fischer
is going to take with his rook here on e
- Paul Benko now plays King to F one he
doesn't have a whole lot of options as
far as where his king can run to but
from here Bobby Fischer's just again as
we talked about with the rook on the
second or seventh ring he can just kind
of gobble up those pieces as he sees fit
so he comes over starts to gobble up
some of that material back over to B -
Paul Benko decides to bring his bishop
to c3 he knows the he's either going to
take this rook here on b2 or as we
talked about this very very nicely
placed night here on d4 he could also
take that as well so from here Bobby
Fischer plays rook to c2 and Paul Benko
decides to capture this night here on d4
so just to show you the power of the
outpost again as we talked about before
this has now become an open game the
bishop pair for white is very very
important but because this outpost from
Knight of blacks Knight was so great not
only did Paul Banco see it fit to trade
off his Bishop for that but he also gave
Bobby Fischer a passed pawn here on d4
just as a side note obviously you can't
play Bobby Fischer because he's dead but
I typically don't recommend giving Bobby
Fischer past pawn just things typically
go horribly wrong but side note from
here Paul Benko plays pawn to e5 opening
up the door so his LightSquared Bishop
can control this long diagonal here also
if he wants to later on he could develop
a passed pawn on the
side of Bobby Fischer now Bobby Fischer
brings his bishop down to e3 Bobby
Fischer does a great job of anytime
there's an outpost for any of his minor
pieces as we saw before with the night
here on d4 he now brings his Bishop to
e3 graced great outpost for his Bishop
obviously this pawn is protected on d4
and this Bishop here on e3 it's pretty
much going to mitigate a lot of the
moves that the King can move and it's
also pretty much just going to just shut
down you know anything that white wants
to do in this general vicinity white now
decides to bring his bishop over to b7
trying to get some of that material back
from here again white is up in material
not for too long
Bobby Fischer now brings his rook over
to f1 White doesn't have a whole lot of
options he brings his king over to e -
there's gonna eat one and now Bobby
Fischer plays pawn to d3 anytime you
have a passed pawn rule number one in
chess push the past pawn pretty simple
concept that's why you see it here with
Bobby Fischer now white knows that he
needs to stop that passed pawn that
passed pawn can easily turn into a queen
without a whole lot of thought from
Bobby Fischer so even if White has to
give back material he needs to make sure
he stops that pawn so that's exactly
what does he plays Bishop to a6 right
here you can kind of see you know this
Bishop right here is about to be traded
off this night right here on a 8s not
doing a whole heck of a lot and this
rook here on a1 has yet to move into the
game and the King for me one is kind of
out in the middle of the board so
although Bobby Fischer doesn't have as
much material he does have a lot more
attacking where this King right here on
g8 is just kind of hanging out and
chillin so from here Bobby Fischer plays
a rook to e2 and now Paul Benko pretty
much makes his last big mistake of the
game instead of kind of moving away from
all the attacking that Bobby Fischer has
he and said plays d1 now he probably
should have played f1 will kind of talk
about that here in a second but after he
plays d1 then Bobby Fischer is just
going to come over here to h2 take this
material and Paul Benko as he has to
he's go ahead and take this pass pawn
here on d3 but now Bobby Fischer
in 2d - he's not only attacking this
King here on d1 with Czech but he's also
attacking the bishop here on d3 now this
would not have happened if the King came
over to f1 but again another huge
mistake by Paul Benko so Bobby Fischer
gobbles up this material after the king
comes over to e1 and Paul Benko tries to
push the little forward all Bobby
Fischer has to do is bring his rook over
to a3 nice little safe square protecting
this bishop here on III and now White
has to get his knight involved into the
game obviously he is down in material
now so he needs to make something happen
in a night on a8 definitely is not doing
a whole lot of good Bobby Fischer from
here can pretty much smell the victory
so as he always does he plays a
fantastic in game he brings his bishop
to a d4 not only attacking this pawn
here on e5 but also attacking the rook
here on a1 anytime you're up in material
you definitely want to be trading down
the more you can trade down the more it
magnifies your actual advantage that you
have so from here pal Benko plays Knight
to b5 it doesn't have a whole lot of
options he is attacking this rook here
on a a3 but Bobby Fischer doesn't care
because he's going to get a two-for-one
he's going to come down take this rook
here on a1 but after the knight takes on
a3 he's going to come back and gobble up
this pawn here on e5 so Bobby Fischer is
now up to pawns in material and he also
has the better minor piece now what I
mean by that is anytime you have pawns
on two sides of the board you actually
would prefer to have a bishop why is
that because there's two sides of the
board you need to attack in two fin
bishops can get around the map much
quicker than a knight so bishops tend to
do well when there's pawns on both sides
of the board and knights actually
pretend to do a little bit better when
there's pawns on only one side of the
board they can pretty much control a lot
of the different moving squares and
moving pieces on one side of the board
so they don't have to move around a lot
they actually outperform bishops on one
side of the board so if you're ever
trying to figure out what you should
trade down to or what position is
better kind of thing in the think of
that how many sides of the board are
there in this situation there are two
sides obviously pawns on the Queen side
and pawns on the Kings side and Bobby
Fischer what do you know has the better
minor piece right here so from here the
Knights excuse me the pawns going to
come up to g4 again is being attacked by
this Bishop here on e5 and then Bobby
Fischer plays King to g7 now any times
you kind of approach the endgame anytime
major pieces the Queen's and Brooks
start to come off the board your King no
longer wants to be safe he no longer
wants to be in a quarter hiding instead
he becomes a valuable asset the first
thing you want to do is centralize your
King you can really really have a strong
attack with your king supporting all
your major and minor pieces so in this
case Bobby Fischer is going to get to
the center of the board as fast as you
can
Paul Benko plays Knight to c4 and Bobby
Fischer just plays King to f6 even
though he does have the better minor
piece if Paul Bangka were to come here
and take here on e5 he's going to have
not only the better central King but he
also is up to pawns in material it's
going to be way too difficult for Paul
Bangka to come back and actually on this
move right here Paul Benko gave ups now
one thing I always like to do when I
analyze the chess game is kind of go
back and think about what I learned
during the game if you just watch a game
and you don't really learn anything from
it I feel like there's kind of a
disconnect as far as improving as a
chess player so kind of something I took
away from this is to trust your instinct
I think one of the biggest mistakes in
this game is actually when Bobby Fischer
played you know his bishop over to h6
we kind of go back in the game you know
instead of go back to moves here once he
played his Bishop here to h6 you know
Paul Benko had a great attack all he had
to do was take one of these rooks here
on H on e8
but instead you know the stage he was on
the first round he definitely didn't
want a mistake I wasn't quite sure if he
was falling into a trap wasn't quite
sure what Bobby Fischer was doing he was
kind of leaving the door open for big
attack from Paul Benko so instead of
trusting his instincts you
he made a big mistake and he started to
play a little bit passive and the huge
advantage that he did have he kind of
gave that back to Bobby Fischer because
he wasn't really sure what was going on
so definitely in your own game when
you're playing you know if you have a
strong attack go with your gut go with
your instinct follow through with that
you know your opponent's going to be
following anything they can ask you so
let them do that and just continue what
you're doing and win the game so
hopefully you guys enjoy this video
again this is the third part of the
upcoming graphic novel Bobby Fischer the
knight who killed the Kings if you want
more information there's a great website
below that has all the information you
would want to know about the upcoming
graphic novel again if you have not
already subscribed to the YouTube
channel so you know when upcoming videos
have just come out definitely feel free
to subscribe if you have a comment about
the video or if you want to just ask me
something feel free to leave a comment
below and also if you wouldn't mind
favoring the video like it the thumbs up
whatever you do below in the video
definitely appreciate it hopefully you
guys enjoy the video and you learn
something I'll see you guys in the next
video
thanks for watching